Facebook is the greatest data company of  all time from a marketers perspective  the reason I love their video product is  if I want to make a video with me  hanging out with Brandon Marshall I can  only target Jets and Bears fans and Gary  Vee and Brandon Marshall fans and that's  called not wasting the content of people  that don't give a crap about it every  other platform has the potential to be  shown to somebody who doesn't give a  crap about it this one really does it  facebook's surgical targeting to make  sure the absolute perfect audience sees  the content is unparalleled at scale the  fact that I could make a video right now  and show it to all Bears fans and jet  fans is incredible for my reach and  awareness and it's surgical and its  depth and its width it's got both  Facebook is right now the biggest scaled  platform the absolute strongest tool to  get video out there